cannes 2006 est finie et le palmarès a
été officiellement annoncée il ya
quelques minutes au cours de la
cérémonie de clôture avec quelques repas
vous voyez la palme d'or a été attribué
à ken loach est puni des récompenses
collectives pour les prix
d'interprétation
six femmes et cinq hommes pour les prix
d'interprétation masculine et féminine
six femmes pour volver de pedro
almodovar et puis six hommes cinq hommes
pour indigènes de rachid bouchared
indigènes qui faut-il le rappeler est
produit par france télévisions nous
sommes donc tous très fiers
compte rendu pascal deschamps c'est le
français brute du nom qui vient de
recevoir le grand prix pour flandres et
c'est la deuxième fois que ce cinéaste
austère exigeant reçoit ce prix lui
était l'un des favoris pour la palme
d'or
alejandro inarritu devra se contenter du
prix de la mise en scène pour babel une
fresque bouleversante sur les frontières
qui divise les hommes on nous avait
promis des surprises ce soir il y en a
eu et de fort belle que nous avait émus
aux larmes dans le film indigènes
ce soir ce sont eux les plus émues là
j'ai une pensée pour pour les soldats
qu'on a représenté dans le film qui eux
n'ont pas eu de récompense donc c'est à
eux que je dédie cette récompense
ma part ce film représente le désir de
toute une génération est en tous les cas
de la mienne et j'espère aussi de bon
nombre de celles qui nous précèdent de
toute une génération donc du besoin de
retrouver sa mémoire son histoire moi je
voulais savoir s'il y en avait qu'un
seul pour des raisons d'ordre
organisationnel
parce que je vais le garder les mecs
sains sa cession ce film a été une leçon
à la fois artistique et humaine très
très fort ensemble ils ont ri thomas
jauch tirailleurs dont il raconte
l'histoire
en chantant le gymnase
autre belle surprise autre prix groupé
les femmes de volver reçoivent ensemble
le prix d'interprétation
une façon de récompenser aussi pedro
almodovar l'homme qui aimait les
actrices
lui qui espérait une palme d'or repart
aussi avec le prix du scénario
vous avez mis tellement de magie dans ma
vie pedro pas seulement dans ma carrière
merci pour tout ce que vous avez fait
pour les femmes dans le monde entier
enfin c'est l'écossaise andrea arnold
qui repart avec le prix du jury pour un
premier film red road